dude if I was a kid and I saw this
wouldn't you just be like this is way
cooler than the regular [ __ ] same [ __ ]
[Music]
so uh
uh Bart you got any updates on your
cyber truck you got a cyber truck though
they don't [ __ ] give you no [ __ ]
update wait did you really downpay a
cyber truck it's only a hundred bucks to
get a pre-order spot yeah and it's so
cool they told me what back in 2019 2020
or some shit's about to be 20 20. it's
because Elon too busy [ __ ] with
Twitter right now that's why he's like
yo Twitter took priority we'll save that
for another conversation before you 2D
do you have an update for me no I have
an update on a different type of thing
what I don't give up not a sniper shirt
that's not a cyber truck I don't give a
[ __ ] then then you could put a down
payment for right now that'll come out
in production in a couple years are you
talking about the BW bus no that sounds
boring I want I need it soon let me show
you I did it soon still not a definite
date it's a futuristic video what do you
think think a futuristic vehicle what do
you think it does
[ __ ] drive itself
that's very realistic of a guess that's
that's not super futuristic because
that's current right invisible Jetson's
car it floats a little bit a spaceship
it floats a little bit does it really it
really does we don't want the first
generation it [ __ ] flies if full-on
[ __ ] flies here's an image
what's that wow that's pretty cool it's
like a hovercraft who's making it okay
answer all those questions Spirit
Airlines
you guys remember those hovercrafts that
like you see them on the rivers and then
all of a sudden they come up to shore
yeah I wonder
yeah ran over people and [ __ ] like that
and but they're fine and you need a
samurai sword in order to [ __ ] stop
it on a car okay
this company right here is creating the
world's first flying car it has a range
of 110 miles in the air wow and can
avoid traffic jams sounds a little too
good yeah but that's fast what if you
hit another car like that are there
Lanes what do you mean what does this
still go on the is it hard for like a
foot above the ground or you're flying
what's the infrastructure okay I'm gonna
show you some videos okay you guys are
you flying flying here we go and how do
you stop here we go let's let's walk
this is some concept videos and then
I'll show you a little bit of uh actual
practical
um but like developmental stage like I
don't like concept videos
so as you can see
those are uh almost like 3D printed
carbon fiber type stuff so it's like
light and there's air that goes through
that means you'll die in an accident
there's propellers under those is there
music there's no music right now I think
it's California plates it's California
so it's a california-based company okay
yep so you know it's going to be high
taxes as you can see through there's
propellers right there
oh they just copied a fan dude
that's a fan [ __ ] right there yeah they
better paint royalties to Thomas fan
Vietnamese guy
oh wait it's real
[Applause]
oh good good thing it's quiet
dude that looks so sketchy bro that's
some Jetson stuff it's like The
Langoliers they don't even look like
they're in control of it it looks I'd
rather be in a hot air balloon
especially it's gonna crash itself
self-crashing vehicle
I feel like one bird is gonna blow up
that whole car is the grass okay I feel
like this is the grass they need to pay
royalties to to bees for that sound so
california-based company uh alef
Aeronautics or a left it looks stupid I
love I love hating on like amazing
technology it is really cool but also
very underwhelming because the concept
looks [ __ ] dope right yeah
it's like one side's going up before the
other side
and the fact the fact that they're
claiming that you can get over traffic
with it if that dude that was inside was
drinking a cup of coffee that's just
cool
if this guy has a terrible coffee that
Terrible's fault it's the car's fault I
love you guys are just [ __ ] ripping
on the developmental phase of the
[ __ ] thing yeah it's first gen we all
get this [ __ ] on first trip well then
isn't again like the whole problem is
the infrastructure for it yeah like you
can make like self-driving cars and then
the country could just go not allowed
yeah and then you can't activate the
tech yeah just like what happened to
Tesla and that's why I feel like I don't
see this happening anytime so this is
this is obviously to work with
potentially uh travel on future
futuristic Road highways so that has to
be an entire I gotta make another road
system yeah
um but how do you make a how do you make
a road for the air maybe it looks like a
tube like Sonic because you got to deal
with all the we none of our power lines
are underground like we're [ __ ] so
behind with that [ __ ] also cops if you
need a cup that's doing speed checks do
they have to be in a floating one yeah
they gotta have a jet pack hey you stop
it yeah they fly over to you here this
is a little this is some concept imagery
I want to see it so it can so look the
the uh see that looks pretty cool the
actual Hub can rotate and gyrate and
then it turns the side of it see this is
what I'm talking about no they're gonna
crash in the air that's [ __ ] if you
run out of gas oh yeah they're gonna fly
and fall down it gives you a range of
110 miles in the air or 220 miles on the
floor people are idiots that can't be a
public thing when it's on E or and you
just imagine a car just dropping out of
the sky and what makes you think they're
gonna be in line in order it's gonna be
like exactly
everywhere dude dude you put my mom on
one of those things almost died
I love the immediate laughter on such a
dark concept
but yeah if you if you want to get one
of these things it's gonna be uh just
around over three hundred thousand
dollars later
and they're PR their plan is to make the
first deliveries in the fourth quarter
of 2025. you wanna know what I think
this could work in Dubai yeah because
you know Dubai has uh they have Uber
helicopter what see that's way better
than this but did that make sense
because they some of the business Deals
they got to go from like building to
building like massive skyscrapers and
it's easy to just take the elevator to
the helipad and just go to the next
place but they got Sharia law though
that's the
downwards I like how you say that but
yeah I guess not for me because I'm a
guy but it's hard to imagine that
working here but I I can imagine working
in like very affluent places yeah that
was one of those genius things about
Elon when he built the cars I was like
what about charging him and he found
locations across the nation he solved
all the problems that it could
potentially yeah like the
infrastructure's like I'll just build it
yeah I'm like that's crazy he goes
what's the problem okay got it and it's
so seamless that like everybody drives a
[ __ ] test there's more and more and
more now yeah there's always more yeah
like they they came to the market
already with these problem solved so
like with something like this it's hard
to kind of get buy-in because you're
like but what about this what about this
what about that and there's no Solutions
but you don't think we're like laughing
at this in the same way that maybe like
Ford and GM were laughing at like Tesla
in the beginning you know what I'm
saying like horse riders laughing at
Ford but then again for a 300 000 car
bro that's crazy this bull went back to
horsepower you know they used to really
make fun of them that's a good point
that is a good point well what if it
[ __ ] does its own thing you know have
you ever seen Neil deGrasse Tyson talk
about how he doesn't believe there will
be uh
became a [ __ ] baby
that was cute never gonna be the flying
cars really he doesn't he doesn't
believe he doesn't believe it'll ever
happen because he said that I don't like
that he said that
he's pissed he said that the concept of
flying cars isn't literal he goes when
you think of road infrastructure and how
a bridge will take you over he goes
That's technically a flying car but
you're just not thinking of it that way
because he goes flying cars is a
dimensional thing he's like oh because
it moves in this third dimension like
yeah you could still solve that problem
by creating better infrastructures for
how cars move so I have more bridges
dude this is why people [ __ ] hate
nerds yeah this is why people are like
yo shut the [ __ ] up we just want a car
like a Jetsons like in the sky yeah [ __ ]
your [ __ ] logic dude yeah but he said
he goes there's a reason why we don't
have them and it's not because we can't
make them because because there's always
a better idea that doesn't involve
flying cars I will say if I had one of
these things and I was like I was like
on a freeway and there was you know just
that red bar just like on [ __ ] ways
or whatever and I could just lift myself
and then go where my exit was and then
just be on the street that'd be kind of
fresh yeah but then so will you and 500
other people and then you cause a red on
top in the sky it's all right on top no
one's below where do you land yeah does
it have wheels if it has wheels then you
can stay on the ground right it drives
over 200 miles or it flies 110 miles all
right isn't that the Chinese bus have
you seen that Chinese bus that's on like
it looks like it's on stilts so it
doesn't cause traffic because it goes
over that's crazy oh Like An Inspector
Gadget car yeah I think this is
different because it [ __ ] flies guys
are we missing the point sponsor did say
that because when you have a flying car
you create downforce of wind and that's
I was asking if the grass is okay and he
said that like you'll you'll never be
able to that's always going to be an
issue to anything underneath you and
then all and then so that's kind of not
fair for whatever the [ __ ] you're going
over plus he said noise wise it'll never
be at a level livable to regular people
like you like that like that [ __ ] dude
people complain about the high
so he's like until those are solved
you're probably not gonna see him for
commercial use for the regular averages
even swamp coolers are [ __ ] loud as
[ __ ] I
don't understand because he said you
could have built that ages ago like it's
not you could have done it before but
that's the reason why they don't because
it's annoying because cars are just a
better product why don't we go to
Roswell knock down the [ __ ] space
base and be like yo
give us a spaceship already
people are they don't have the
capability man to knock down a space
space don't say it like that okay I mean
the responsibility to to use one of
these so Anthony are you it sounds like
you're a fan
I'm a I'm a fan of and dude if I was a
kid and I saw this wouldn't you just be
like this is way cooler than me it's the
same [ __ ] that thing's [ __ ] the the
night is [ __ ] rain
but he's not getting for years nah that
shit's dope you [ __ ] rain on this
[ __ ] the fans break yeah dude
that's the number one thing that they
didn't think about weather imagine a
bird getting in that thing you're gonna
have a blended bird in your car come on
that's just gonna [ __ ] go and then
all this Blood goes inside of the car
you guys are killing creativity but okay
what do you see I supported the Cyber
truck yeah when you see the when you see
the the Prototype what are your true
thoughts yeah go back to that not the
concert video the real one real video
because I was a fan of the the concert
video dude I was all in until I saw that
video then I go what is this and I'm
like I might as well just take a bird
cage take a bunch of vornados underneath
and I saw the [ __ ] hurt grass the
hurt grass it's getting [ __ ]
destroyed by this stupid car sympathizer
[Music]